hey guys Pete here after the Game of
Thrones season 7 finale I put out some
character predictions for the next
season and today I'm gonna expand on
those and look at the big events I think
that will happen in season 8 of course
this will contain spoilers about
everything that has happened in the
first seven seasons of Game of Thrones
Plus educated guesses on what will
happen in the final season if you're not
caught up with the entire series this
video won't be for you
so you're gonna want to go watch
something else with that out of the way
let's look what makes sense prior to
filming getting underway next month it's
worth noting that there are no credible
script leaks or production news so this
is purely speculation based on what
we've seen what I think and what I've
read and you guys can tell me afterwards
if you think I'm on the right track or
not so one thing that's pretty easy to
guess is that Daenerys and Jon will
arrive in Winterfell along with the rest
of the people who's traveling in that
entourage I say probably here because
there's important stuff for them to do
at Winterfell and we'll get into where
we think that the night king and the
White Walkers are gonna go and it should
be fine
cuz Daenerys and John are on a boat
they're heading to white Harbor which is
a port near Winterfell in the north
they'll land there and we know that the
night king just broke down or went
through the wall so they'll be on the
move and I think that just means that
Daenerys and John will arrive at
Winterfell right away right in the very
beginning of season 8 they're gonna have
to get things together and get ready for
this imminent attack they'll get there
soon enough to learn about what's
happened and we'll see some major major
reunions character reunions which I'll
get to in a minute but I was talking
about the 19 so let's talk about where
he'll go he moved through the wall at
Eastwatch so he'll probably hit the last
hearth and or karhold first and we got a
hint about this from John in the season
7 premiere he said if they breach the
wall the first two castles in their path
last hearth and car hole if we look on
the map you can see where those are
located and where Winterfell is and
there is a slight chance that they won't
even go to Winterfell if they're headed
towards King's Landing say but we also
saw what was probably some poor
shadowing when John put the two young
people in front of those two castles and
charged them I should say so
it was Ned umber you remember and Alice
Karstark they were children when that
may turn out to be a bad choice since
those castles would fall either way but
you know people can point to that as
something John did that didn't make any
sense something that's interesting about
the night king going through the wall
that you might not have thought of it
dawned on me a little bit later after
the season wrapped up but people in the
north in Westeros in general don't burn
their dead obviously they bury them as
the night king and his army moves south
so they'll probably be raising up
thousands of corpses possibly we saw
quite a few shots of their army lining
up at the wall whatever he did his
Viserion show so we can imagine that a
lot of those people died fighting them
north of the wall except maybe the
Giants which we do know that Giants get
buried and in relation to the fake Horn
of Joramun that they had when they said
they found with the giant and baked
possibly back in older generations the
wildlings buried their dead but they've
been burning them for quite some time
now because they've seen them turn so
once they cross into Westeros see soil
they could possibly just bring all kinds
of people back up from underneath the
ground which will make for a pretty
creepy skeleton army as well if you
think about it there could be some
people that we've heard of in the story
that come back and I think it's a pretty
safe guess that people who are fighting
against them on the good side will get
turned and we'll see a bit of that
throughout the season obviously a white
Hodor
is something people have talked about
quite a bit over time that could pop up
and just anybody that's dead in the
north basically may eventually reprise
their role as a white version of
themselves so as I mentioned when John
de niro
I've a series of crazy reunions are
gonna go down most importantly the one
that everybody's been waiting for and
that is John and Aria we don't you know
we've been waiting for that forever and
it's going to happen it didn't happen in
season seven which means it has to
happen pretty fast in season eight these
two cousins had a very close
relationship when they thought they were
brother and sister or at least
half-brother half-sister if you remember
John was the one who gave Arie a needle
he had it made for her as a goodbye
present when she went to King's Landing
and they were very very close so I think
that there will be a tearful reunion
whenever those two get together before
the night king gets there to mess things
up another one for John will be seeing
Sam again they sent Sam away from the
wall to become a maester at the Citadel
and that was obviously before John died
so down at the to sit at all I'm sure
that Sam had learned about he knows that
he's alive but he probably heard about
the assassination and the resurrection
so that should make for some interesting
conversation also we know that Sam and
bran know about exactly what happened
with John's birth and his parents
Rhaegar and Lyanna so he'll be there to
handle that and that's gonna be pretty
exciting if you think about it these are
those are two big things that we've been
waiting for forever that are gonna
happen at Winterfell so that should
change things around a little bit
compared to the season seven Winterfell
and of course I just said it but I'll
say it again bran and John will get
together that hasn't happened for quite
some time if you remember bran saw him
at Craster's
Craster's keep John just found out that
Brandon Arya were still alive whenever
he got the raven and he's gonna be super
excited to talk to both of them and i
can't wait to see it myself i mean it
should be pretty cool another big
advancement for John's story will
probably be when he starts to ride ragel
Rhaegar was named for his father and is
the last unclaimed dragon now that the
night
has vissarion so we saw this floor
shattered heavily last season when John
was able to touch drogon without any
issues like I said there's only one
unclaimed dragon and John is the only
one in the running to actually ride the
train since we know that she and he are
the last Targaryen zand these are the
last two dragons there's really no
question that that's gonna happen will
it happen on the way north or will it
happen when they get there it depends I
mean I can't really say I'm sure that
it's gonna coincide with something very
important like he's gonna need to
convince somebody about something and
this will happen and that will be the
convince er that's the way I look at it
you figure there's gonna be some
problems whenever he comes back with the
Queen and he's been sleeping with her
maybe that's gonna be the thing that's
gonna stop them from bickering or trying
to think about putting someone else in
this place if he shows them that he is
actually a dragon rider which is a
pretty good thing to have around if
you're fighting an army of the Dead also
in the Dragons vissarion's gonna have to
be dealt with
obviously the knight King can't just
continue to have that so I'm sure that
it's probably going to be drogon that
takes him on one on one and eventually
knocks him out it makes a bit of sense
in the same way that John riding Ragle
because that's his father's name
vissarion was a name for Viserys and
drogon was named for Khal Drogo Khal
Drogo killed Viserys and I think drogon
will kill vissarion I'm not sure when
that will happen you would think that
that would happen in the ultimate battle
the final stand and that in that process
the night King goes down too but that
has a lot to do with that what what Sam
and bran find out and we'll talk about
that in a second the main thing the main
way that I don't see that happening the
night king going down with Vissarion is
if somehow the night king loses his
mount but is able to kill Danny and her
mount in the process and one of the
things we have to keep in mind
throughout this upcoming season is that
Daenerys is probably
have to be pregnant as a result of her
sexual relations with John alright so I
realized when I was recording this that
it's going to go too long so I'm gonna
break it up into two parts gonna end
part one right here and then I will edit
the rest of it down into a part two for
tomorrow so make sure you check back for
that I'll be doing more Season eight
videos obviously filming I'll get
kicking off and then I'll start doing
ones about that Plus individual
character predictions or my next thing
so like this video if you enjoyed it let
me know in the comments what you're
hoping to see make sure you subscribe to
my channel I'll be doing videos all
throughout the off season turn on
notification so you know when they come
out I started a patreon so you can check
that out you can get involved in
choosing what I do videos on voting on
what you want to see next
and it's you know you can start at any
level and it all helps because I need
some new equipment and I want to make
good videos instead of chasing views so
you know how that goes
got to follow me on Twitter and my other
social media accounts too so we can
interact thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon